qu'y at il de commun entre l'innovation
et l'illusionnisme entre un objet
innovants et un tour de magie tout c'est
exactement la même chose
une innovation comme un tour de magie ou
une illusion c'est ce qui rend possible
l'impossible j'ai ici le prototype d'une
boîte testé en ce moment par une société
de transport pour faciliter leur envoi
de colis
la particularité de cette boîte c'est
que le contenant peut devenir le contenu
pour ceux qui ont déjà décroché je vous
montre si j'ouvre le colis à l'intérieur
il ya une seconde boîte un cadeau et si
j'ouvre le cadeau eh bien on peut ranger
à l'intérieur du cadeau le colis le
contenant dans le contenu est ce un
objet innovants ou un tour de magie
en réalité c'est une illusion d'optique
et cette illusion d'optique
vous ne l'avez pas comprise parce que
vous ne saviez pas exactement ce qui
allait arriver
la force du magicien c'est toujours
d'avoir un temps d'avancé sur le public
comme une innovation qui a toujours un
temps d'avancé sur le marché sur les
clients
moi même j'ai commencé comme consultant
en innovation et puis je me suis
retrouvé sur une scène de théâtre à
faire des spectacles d'illusionnisme et
je me suis aperçu que je faisais le même
métier et pour vous expliquer je
voudrais vous proposer une démonstration
et soyez attentifs à mes gestes
au moindre détail de ce qui va se passer
car je vais tenter quelque chose avec un
membre du public
je vois à présent que tout le monde
baisse les yeux
tout le monde baisse les yeux et
regardons par ici quel est votre prénom
madame anne anne venue me rejoindre sur
scène on peut vous applaudir venez and
je vous en prie vous les paris sur la
scène musicale
on ne se connaît pas n'est ce pas que
vous n'êtes pas complices vous ne savez
pas ce qui va suivre vous le prométhée
n'est ce pas am je vais vous demander
d'imaginer un écran blanc n'est ce pas
et sur cet écran blanc de projeter un
nombre entre 50 et 100 le nombre que
vous voulez vous avez un nombre en tête
garder le bien dans votre esprit ne dit
rien voulu laver en tête parfait and
classer vos demain comme ceux ci face à
moi et penser disons je dirai au
deuxième chiffres de votre nombre penser
au deuxième chiffres de notre votre
nombre et c'est cette hausse est un
chiffre c'est un chiffre un père n'est
ce pas oui c'est ça vous le faites très
bien allez-y penser au deuxième chiffres
de votre nombre deuxième chiffre à
nouveau c'est le sait le set le deuxième
chiffre c'est le set très bien très bien
pensé à nouveau aux premiers chiffres de
votre nombre je vous en prie vous en
fils
je vous en prie juste du bout des doigts
du bout des doigts regardez moi et
penser aux premiers chiffres à c'est un
nombre impair à nouveau oui rester ici
ne bougeait pas repenser à votre nom
projeté sur l'écran blanc projeté le
nombre sur l'écran blanc garder le à
l'esprit en innovation pour trouver une
idée pertinente
il faut je dirais générer beaucoup
d'idées générer un grand nombre d'idées
et surtout ne pas les juger par exemple
jeté sur le papier des idées qui semble
original
d'autres plus ou moins réalisables
certaines complètement surprenante il
faut jeter sur le papier des idées sans
pour autant les juger
anne vous avez toujours votre votre
nombre en tête n'est ce pas allez-y
pensez à votre nom ne vous arrêtez pas
pensé vous y êtes
continuant à jeter des idées peut-être
ici et peut-être je dirais aulas est
peut-être un avant dernier 1-4 et pour
finir nous choisirons le cinquante sept
ânes and pour la première fois sur cette
grille and voyez-vous votre nombre non
vous ne le voyez pas anne placez-vous
ici je vous en prie vous savez anne qui
lit à haute voix le nombre que vous
aviez en tête à nouveau que tout le
monde vous entendent bien 177 vous savez
and en innovation comme en illusionnisme
il faut savoir changer de perspective 57
plus haut est égal à 58,58 +12 + 7 77 11
+ 8 est égal à 19,19 +56 +28 égal à
77,59 plus 3,59 +3 +10 +5 est égal à
77,9 +69 +6 +58 +4 est égal à 77,1 a
fait osciller verticale 57 plus aux 57
plus en plus 5 + 4 77 8 plus est égal à
9,9 plus il cale à 19,19 plus 58 77 12
+56 tous +56 + 3 + 6 77 excuse est égal
à 9 9 et 9 est égale à 18 18 + 59 77
elle a fait l'écart et ou si elle a fait
l'écart et 57 + 1 58 plus juste bon 77
12 7 est égale à dix neuf plus de plus
56 77 5 ans le plus 3 puis 6 pouces 9 77
10 plus inquiété à la casse jusqu'à + 58
le centre le centre 56 +8 +10 plus 3,77
messieurs pense au diagonal les
diagonales 57-57 +8 +3 +9 est égal à
77,7 puce 56,7 +56 +10 plus 4,77 les
coins les coins 57 plus fait plus neuf
+ 4 57 +7 +9 +4 est égale 1 bravo vous
avez été formidables
on peut vous applaudir je vous en prie
vous lui donnez votre place
que s'est il passé ici
tout l'enjeu de l'illusionniste consiste
à exploiter une faille de notre cerveau
notre capacité à faire des raccourcis à
ne pas poser les bonnes questions en
voyant cette expérience vous avez
peut-être penser à à du calcul rapide
vous vous êtes dit c'est un génie du sud
au cou ou bien vous avez pensez
peut-être un effort de mémorisation voie
de la communication non verbale n'est ce
pas
ce sont des solutions possibles mais ne
sont elles pas trop évidente et pour
l'innovateur l'enjeu est le même il faut
apprendre à remettre en cause l'évidence
et à poser les bonnes questions et en
innovation une bonne question c'est
celle qui remet en question
c'est une question courageuse mais qui
n'en a pas l'air une question qui
commence par pourquoi pourquoi pas et si
un enfant c'est la même chose
il pose des questions sincère auquel il
n'a pas la réponse
prenez l'exemple de polaroïd par exemple
qui connaît aujourd'hui une renaissance
grâce à l'esprit vintage un jour son
inventeur prend en photo sa fille avec
un appareil photo classique et sa fille
qui veut voir la photo tout de suite ne
comprends pas pourquoi il faut attendre
elle insiste elle repose la question
face à une question naïve l'innovateur
se demande toujours pourquoi pas ici la
photo pouvait être instantané comment
cela pourrait-il marché l'enjeu du
magicien c'est de jouer avec le
questionnement du public mais pour y
arriver il doit maîtriser également une
autre compétence tout aussi importante
pour l'innovateur c'est sa capacité
entré dans la tête des spectateurs ça ne
veut pas dire bien sûr que je peux lire
dans votre esprit
mais ça veut dire que pour vous étonner
pour vous surprendre je dois adopter
votre perspective et ressentir vos
émotions prise de perspectives et
capacité d'empathie de la même manière
en innovation on doit se glisser dans la
peau du client en se demandant quels
sont les problèmes qu'ils rencontrent
quelles sont ses plus grandes
frustrations quels sont les obstacles
qui se dressent entre ce qu'il veut
faire et ce qu'il fait vraiment
percevoir le problème auquel est
confronté le client c'est la première
étape d'une solution innovante est un
bon exemple de prise de perspectives
c'est ce qu'a fait récemment facebook
facebook
aujourd'hui il souhaite étendre son
nombre d'utilisateurs en inde et en inde
une partie du réseau internet et en 2g
afin que les collaborateurs au siège aux
etats unis puissent se mettre à la place
des clients naviguent en 2g
facebook a lancé au siège les mardis de
g tous les mardis l'ensemble des
collaborateurs sont invités à ralentir
leur mobile en 2g et à identifier tout
ce qui peut les gêner lors de leur
navigation afin de concevoir des applis
particulièrement adapté pour l'inde
donc deux clés importantes à retenir ici
pour innover l'art de poser les bonnes
questions et la prise de perspectives et
j'en vois encore au premier rang qui
fixent toujours la grille n'est ce pas
vous le loup la fixer fixement un
directement vous cherchez le truc n'est
ce pas mais il n'y a pas un truc mais
plusieurs un bon numéro d'illusionnisme
consiste à combiner plusieurs idées
plusieurs principes pour un seul et même
tour comme ici un principe mathématique
avec une forme de détournement
d'attention
la combinaison
est une excellente manière de générer
des idées nouvelles qui peuvent
peut-être un jour devenir de belles
innovations
même les plus grands ont utilisé cette
technique but imbert par exemple a
inventé l'imprimerie
en combinant la presse du vigneron et le
coin du monnayeur le savent en inde elle
a pensé la génétique en combinant
mathématiques et biologie et plus près
de nous google est également le fruit
d'une combinaison puisque larry page à
combiner la logique de citations des
articles universitaires avec la
recherche sur le web
et comme le disait steve jobs la
créativité c'est savoir relier les
choses entre elles on a posé les bonnes
questions
on a appris du client et on a identifié
certains de ces problèmes
on a peut être trouvé une solution
nouvelle en combinant deux idées par
exemple que fait-on à présent et bien on
fait une étude de marché
un benchmark une analyse saute on rédige
un business plan on consolide le
business model on fait une analyse des
risques
on croit creuser l'idée mais en réalité
on repousse sa mise en oeuvre
en accumulant les études ont fait de
l'idée un idéal au lieu d'en faire une
réalité on passe souvent trop de temps à
vouloir affiner l'idée au lieu de la
tester de l'expérimenté rapidement au
contact des clients comme pour
l'illusionniste d'ailleurs un tour sur
le papier n'est rien sans le public
quel est votre votre prénom à haute voix
dit non christelle christelle
pourriez-vous venir me rejoindre sur
salon pas vous applaudir veulent et
christelle je vous en prie vous les
policiers
je vous en prie système
christelle nous parions de tester
d'expérimentation et pour terminer je
voudrais tenter quelque chose que je
n'ai jamais essayé auparavant d'accord
vous allez tenter d'inverser les rôles
pour une fois l'espace d'un instant vous
allez essayer d'être mentaliste d'accord
et j'ai un test pour vous placez-vous
face au public je vous en prie j'ai ici
une enveloppe
c'est une enveloppe au pas quand on ne
peut absolument rien voir au travers
n'est ce pas christelle christelle vous
le promets tvo jury pour les spectateurs
ici présent on ne se connaît pas n'est
ce pas vous ne savez pas si ça va
réussir vous n'êtes pas complice n'est
ce pas parfait christelle à l'intérieur
de cette enveloppe
il y a une feuille de papier sur la
feuille de papier est inscrit un nombre
entre 100 et 500 votre défi sera de
tenter de deviner ce nombre ça va aller
christelle christelle vous n'allez pas
ouvrir les enveloppes bien sûr prenez-le
enveloppe entre vos mains et regardez
moi dans les yeux et imaginez devant
vous comme tout à l'heure un écran blanc
imaginez un écran blanc et vous allez
tenter de trouver ce nombre entre 100 et
500 chiffres par chiffres
instinctivement projeté le premier
chiffre sur l'écran blanc
vous avez le premier chiffre qui
apparaît clairement à haute voix que
tout le monde vous entendent bien quel
est le premier chiffre selon vous le
numéro un parfait sans quelque chose
alors un à nouveau vous allez projeté le
second chiffre le second chiffre projeté
le second chiffre maintenant vous avez
le second chiffre dit non à haute voix
que tout le monde vous entendent bien
jusqu'au fond le 5
vous êtes sûr de vous pas trop je vais
reposer la question et vous allez dire
oui je suis sûr de moi christelle le 5
vous êtes sûr de vous j'aime votre état
d'esprit et christelle vous pensez que
c'est le 150 quelque chose n'est-ce pas
le dernier chiffre va vous apparaître
directement
maintenant à haute voix dit nous le le 7
1 5 7 vous pensez qu'à l'intérieur de
cette enveloppe
il y a le numéro 157 n'est ce pas et
christelle vous ne voulez pas changer
plutôt 157 christelle vous savez à force
de test et d'expérimentation en
innovation comment ni lu sionisme
on peut rendre possible l'impossible
vous avez été formidables
merci christelle en jeu vous applaudir
je vous en prie merci beaucoup tardé
s'en souvenir 157
je vous en prie merci christelle merci
merci merci de votre attention
merci beaucoup